die deutsche einheit ist also kein
zustand einmal vollendet und
abgeschlossen sondern ein fortwährender
prozess ständiger auftrag ein prozess
der alle deutschen betrifft sagt
kanzlerin merkel am tag der deutschen
einheit den hunderttausende in kiel
feiern
tatort polizeizentrale im pariser
präsidium sticht ein mitarbeiter auf
seine kollegen ein
vier polizisten sterben urteil gegen
hass im netz wer online beleidigt wird
kann facebook und co zwingen diese und
ähnliche postings zu löschen und das im
weltweit urteilte der europäische
gerichtshof
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick am dritten
oktober auch sport geht es heute mit
norbert lehmann veranstalter von mir
deutschland feiert seine einheit diesmal
im hohen norden
beim festakt in kiel war kanzlerin
merkel für mehr gegenseitiges
verständnis im westen hätten die meisten
menschen die wender ist zuschauer erlebt
für die ostdeutschen folgte der gegen
zitat auf die last der teilung die wucht
der einigung heute vor 29 jahren
[Musik]
und mit der nacht leute die
freiheitsglocke aus dem schöneberger
rathaus als symbol für das vereinte
deutschland fast ein jahr nach dem
mauerfall und 45 jahre nach ende des
zweiten weltkriegs wird aus zwei staaten
wieder ein deutschland grund zu feiern
auch heute aus kiel berichtete einer
hebestreit begleitet von strengen
sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch auf der kieler
förde feiern hunderttausende in
schleswig holsteins landeshauptstadt den
tag der deutschen einheit
es ist ein fröhliches fest bei dem ganz
deutschland vertreten ist die
bundesländer präsentieren gesamtdeutsche
vielseitigkeit bremer stadtmusikanten
rheinische frohnaturen und hausgemachte
wurst aus brandenburg auf der kieler
fest meile ist die deutsche einheit
angekommen im alltag scheint sie noch
unvollendet die einsichten der bürger in
den alten sind unterschiedlich luft nach
oben ist immer aber ich würde sagen das
hat sich auf alle fälle verbessert weiß
nicht ob da immer noch so ein paar
diskrepanzen von der geschichte her sind
und dass sich die leute im osten
irgendwie benachteiligt fühlen
unsere wird kanzlerin merkel beim
offiziellen festakt um verständnis für
die ostdeutschen es gehöre zur bilanz
nach 29 jahren wiedervereinigung dass
sich die mehrheit der ostdeutschen als
bundesbürger zweiter klasse fühlt
ausdrücklich würdigt sie das ostdeutsche
selbstverständnis das im
einigungsprozess wohl möglich unter die
räder gekommen ist hatten wir auch
ausreichend bedacht dass der einzelne
mensch und beileibe nicht nur offiziere
und volkspolizisten sondern wir alle die
wir in der ddr gelebt hatten dass der
einzelne mensch sein denken fühlen und
erfahren nicht einfach an der garderobe
abgeben kann und dass er das vielleicht
auch gar nicht will dass ich jetzt
bestimmte politische kräfte dieser
ostdeutschen erfahrungen bedienen wollen
ist für bundesratspräsident günther und
tragbar und es ist eine verhöhnung der
leistung dieser menschen wenn partei
diesen mut heute für ihre
parteipolitischen zwecke missbrauchen
indem sie von der wende 2.0 reden diese
wende als historische lebensleistung der
ostdeutschen bleibt sie
julia und untrennbar mit dem ende der
ddr verbunden meine damen und herren
gewürdigt wurde die friedliche
revolution der ostdeutschen auch im
ökumenischen gottesdienst den
historischen prozess der einheit der
deutschen zu vollenden dürfte aber auch
die nächste generation noch beschäftigen
ja und da wäre es jedenfalls hilfreich
wenn sich westdeutsche einfach mal dafür
interessierten wie ostdeutsche früher
gelebt haben
denn auch wenn die ddr ein start war der
seine bevölkerung hinter mauer und
stacheldraht ein schwerte sogar bis in
privaten für die meisten doch einen ganz
normalen und durchaus erfreulichen
alltag wie jetzt auch in hunderten
private aufnahmen von ddr hobby filmen
zu sehen
katrin lindner über ein besonderes
erinnerungsprojekt mit einer schmalfilm
kamera hat heinz stille sein leben
festgehalten den alltag in der ddr seien
plattenbauviertel in potsdam seine frau
und ihre zwei kinder als ein aufruf kam
die schmalfilme einzuschicken hat er
keinen moment gezögert wie 150 andere
familien ganze pakete mit filmaufnahmen
kamen mit der post auf ihnen party
szenen besuch beim friseur oder bilder
von ausflügen
ich habe die filme alle stapelt alle
nacheinander zusammengeklebt um die
nachwelt dazu zeigen wie schön alles war
dass die ddr gesehen wird wie wiese war
die idee kommt von einem kanadischen
politologen und einem deutsch
schwedischen filmemacher sie haben vier
jahre lang fast 2300 filmrollen
archiviert über 400 stunden ddr alltag
für jeden zugänglich im internet
sie wollen zeigen dass es in der ddr
auch ein ganz normales leben gab
die ds nicht nur dass leute im osten
diese bilde sich anschauen sich über
ihre vergangenheit freuen sondern dass
leute im westen auch sehen hier würde
auch ein schönes leben geführt
mit unserer anderen bedingungen und dass
die leute so ins dialog kommen und sich
gegenseitig anerkennen und damit endlich
zusammenwachsen kann was zusammengehört
die bundesstiftung zur aufarbeitung der
sed diktatur hat das projekt unterstützt
ein archiv der visuellen erinnerungen an
den alltag in einem verschwunden im land
an den hans stiller noch heute gern
denkt auch eine tradition am dritten
oktober der tag der offenen moschee
heute hatten wieder rund 1000
muslimische gotteshäuser in deutschland
ihre türen für die besucher geöffnet
so auch die ditib zentralmoschee in köln
ehrenfeld
ziel der veranstaltung ist es über den
islam zu informieren und mit
interessierten nichtmuslimen ins
gespräch zu kommen
im mittelpunkt stand in diesem jahr das
thema heimat knapp fünf wochen nach der
landtagswahl steuert sachsen auf eine
koalition aus cdu grünen und spd zu
die sondierungsgespräche wurden heute
beendet jetzt wollen die
verhandlungsführer der parteien in den
jeweiligen gremien für
koalitionsverhandlungen werden ein
angriff mit fünf toten hat heute paris
aufgeschreckt im hauptquartier der
polizei sticht ein mann mit einem messer
auf vier polizisten ein wird dann selbst
getötet
er war ein mitarbeiter sein motiv ist
noch unklar
thomas walde aus paris der täter kam aus
den eigenen reihen ein mitarbeiter der
pariser polizeipräfektur griff ihr am
frühen nachmittag mit einem messer
kolleginnen und kollegen an bis er
selbst von einem polizisten mit dessen
dienstwaffe gestoppt wurde
es gibt fünf tote darunter den mann der
mit dem messer angegriffen hatte
das ist extrem schockierend die kollegen
können dieses tragische ereignis nicht
fassen
die polizei sperrte die gegend um die
präfekturen der pariser in
statt ab sie behandelt den angriff als
mord war ich habe sofort eine
untersuchung eingeleitet und sie der
einheit der polizei für kriminelle taten
übertragen wie dies hier der angriff
kommt in einem sensiblen moment gestern
zogen mehr als 20.000 polizisten durch
paris sie protestierten gegen
überlastung in folge zahlreiche einsätze
bei gelb westen protesten mehr als 50
polizisten haben sich in diesem jahr in
frankreich bereits das leben genommen
die beamten verlangen mehr unterstützung
die französische nationalversammlung
legte eine schweigeminute ein für die
opfer des angriffs heute präsident
premier und in den minister eilten zum
tatort
mit der mann war seit vielen jahren in
der abteilung zur nachrichten
verarbeitung bekannt wo er mit seinen
kollegen zusammen arbeitete ohne
auffälligkeiten in seinem verhalten es
gab niemals anlass zu besorgen
beamte durchsuchten die wohnung des
täters über sein mögliches motiv haben
die behörden bislang keine angaben
gemacht
heute ankara morgen athen eine
schwierige reise für innenminister
seehofer es geht um das flüchtlings
abkommen zwischen der eu und der türkei
am späten nachmittag ist seehofer in
ankara von seinem türkischen minister
kollegen empfangen worden
zuletzt waren wieder deutlich mehr
migranten von der türkei aus nach
griechenland und damit in die eu
gekommen
der vertrag von 2016 soll das eigentlich
eindämmen
doch der deal wackelt die türkische
regierung fordert unter anderem mehr
geld von der eu die usa haben strafzölle
auf eu produkte angekündigt die
welthandelsorganisation hatte ja die
erlaubnis dazu gegeben
start soll in zwei wochen sein für die
einfuhr von flugzeugen will washington
eine abgabe von zehn prozent erheben für
andere produkte wie käse butter und wein
25 prozent die eu warnte die usa sollten
sie die strafzölle erheben werde man das
gleiche tun zu einem wegweisenden urteil
des europäischen gerichtshofs es geht um
beleidigungen und hass kommentare im
internet
gerichte dürfen online dienste künftig
zwingen das netz auf schmähungen zu
durchsuchen weltweit und sie zu löschen
facebook und co sehen das urteil
kritisch und verweisen auf die
meinungsfreiheit felix zimmermann die
frühere grünen-vorsitzende aus
österreich die verwies nick und ihrer
anwältin können heute einen sieg gegen
den internetgiganten facebook feiern
der fall als sich die ehemalige
politikerin für die versorgung von
flüchtlingen aussprach wurde sie im netz
als korruptes trampel beschimpft dass
einer faschisten partei angehöre
das war einfach nicht mehr erträglich
dass ich das jeden tag an zuschauern ja
und wir haben uns dann eigentlich
bewusst entschieden hier auch eine rote
linie zu ziehen
sie klagte gegen facebook und gewann
facebook aber erste nur die eine
beleidigung für österreich weigerte sich
aber sinn gleiche beleidigungen zu
suchen und auch diese zu entfernen
das problem beleidigungen im internet
verbreiten sich rasend schnell
andere user teilen die inhalte und
wiederholen sie teilweise mit sinnen
gleichen worten machen beispielsweise
aus einem korrupten trampel ein
korruptes trampeltier frustrieren für
betroffene wenn massenhaft fast
identische beleidigungen online bleiben
heute entschied nun der europäische
gerichtshof nationale gerichte dürfen
facebook verpflichten nicht nur
identische sondern auch sinn gleiche
beleidigungen zu suchen und diese zu
entfernen und das sogar weltweit statt
etwa nur in österreich
das kritisiert facebook in einer
stellungnahme scharf das urteil
untergräbt den langjährigen grundsatz
dass ein land nicht das recht hat einem
anderen land seine gesetze aufzuerlegen
der europäische gerichtshof hat heute
einen wendepunkt im kampf gegen hass im
netz eingeleitet und zwar die
verpflichtung anerkannt dass facebook
und co auch sinn gleiche beleidigungen
suchen und löschen müssen
damit stärkt europäische gerichtshof die
persönlichkeitsrechte der eu-bürger und
wir sind beim sport und bei der
fußball-champions-league na ja und da
hat borussia dortmund gestern abend
endlich mal wieder gewonnen dank hakims
doppelpack nach drei pflichtspielen ohne
sieg und leichter krisenstimmung tankte
der bvb mit dem 2 0
auswärtserfolg gegen slavia prag wieder
selbstvertrauen dass ashraf al kini zwei
tore in einem spiel geschossen hat ist
lange her sehr lange da war ich noch
ziemlich klein
eigentlich ist der marokkaner
abwehrspieler gegen prag agiert er aber
als flügelstürmer und kann seine immense
schnelligkeit ausspielen
das 1 0 erzielte er nach 39 minuten kurz
vor schluss folgt das 20
die idee hakimi als offensivkraft
einzusetzen ist eine gute von bvb
trainer lucien favre
weniger gut ist dass der bvb sich lange
schwer tut prag chancen ermöglicht und
viele eigene nicht nutzen kann
immerhin durch das zwei zu null steht
dortmund an der spitze der champions
league gruppe f ist diese gruppe
weiterhin herausfordernde ist es klar
der sieg heute gibt aber definitiv erst
mal ein gutes gefühl dass heute uns vor
allem auch am samstag helfen in freiburg
wo der bvb durch einen sieg den
anschluss an die bundesliga
tabellenspitze halten will
rb leipzig dagegen mit probleme nach den
verlorenen bundesliga-heimspiel letzten
samstag und der verlorenen
tabellenführung jetzt dasselbe spiel in
der königsklasse 0 2 zu hause gegen
olympique lyon und nur noch platz drei
in der gruppe g ja und probleme hatte
heute auch kalk schmierig deutschlands
bislang bester zehnkämpfer bei der
leichtathletik wm am zweiten
wettkampftag in doha für ihn war der
wettbewerb nach sechs disziplinen
praktisch bereits beendet der wm-dritte
von 2017 schied über 110 meter hürden
nach einem wackler aus ja und hat damit
keine chance mehr auf eine vordere
platzierung
teamkollege und u23-europameister niclas
kohl dagegen ist noch im rennen um
bronze
ja und die entscheidung die welt so kurz
vor mitternacht und wir feiern am
dritten oktober auch noch ein ganz
anderes jubiläum nämlich der berliner
fernsehturm wird 50 mit 368 metern ist
er das höchste bauwerk in deutschland
1969 eröffnet damals noch eine reine ddr
attraktion jetzt 50 jahre später ist er
einen touristen magneten mitten in der
hauptstadt und gilt als
ein symbol des wiedervereinigten berlin
die wetteraussichten für morgen im
westen regnet es bereits am vormittag im
tagesverlauf wandert der regen dann
immer weiter nach osten maximal 9 bis 14
grad
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
marietta slomka meldet sich um 21 uhr 45
und wir sind morgen abend wieder für sie
da
punkt 7 hier an dieser stelle noch einen
schönen dritter oktober wünschen batches